las vegas is hosting the annual national
homeland security conference and it's
happening over at the mgm grand as
hector mejia reports clark county is
showcasing how local agencies respond to
emergencies when they strike
the spotlight is on nevada and las vegas
around 1200 people representing agencies
from all over the nation are in town for
the conference we're talking about
homeland security law enforcement fire
and emergency management ranging from
non-profits to federal agencies they'll
go over emergency trends and best
practices the theme this year is
resiliency when it comes to las vegas
we've had our own share of major
incidents clark county fire chief john
steinbeck says they'll highlight a few
the one october massacre on the las
vegas strip the pandemic and our ongoing
response to it also how las vegas works
to keep millions of visitors safe every
year we compete for funding federal
funding all the time this is a chance
for us to showcase what it is that we're
protecting in this community how vital
it is and and what it is that we do with
the funding
of course las vegas added its own flair
with showgirls and the vegas golden
knights drumbots this is the 14th year
for the conference it was held virtually
last year the conference is going on
until thursday that's when things wrap
up reporting from the mgm grand
conference center hector mejia 8 news
now